have you ever done an extreme sport
um like skateboarding or anything like
rolled around
a lot of skateboarders boss just really
were just doing drugs you know they
owned the boards but they was mostly
just for you know setting their drugs on
while they would roll them up but we
didn't have a lot of i'm trying to think
if we had extreme sports bus yeah we had
these guys that used to shoot these
potato guns like uh
they had like a rest area bus i don't
know if they have it on and maybe in
australia your whole country's like a
rest area actually but it's like a rest
area is like a place where you stop on
the side of the interstate when you're
driving yeah yeah and people like get
out to use the restroom and drink water
change the baby you know
you usually have a cigarette and then
get back in the van and keep going you
know someone beat the kids or whatever
but um if they've been bad yeah yeah but
not uh but anyway by us there was a
there was one of those and behind it
they had a river
and a lot of gay men would meet up at
these places because it was like a um
you know it was like on the outskirts of
town some gay men would meet up over
there and
you know do drugs and make out and stuff
yeah and
across the river that's where i lived so
a lot of men over there some would not a
lot but they had these two guys that
would make like potato these potato gun
launchers yeah and if like a lot of like
like real high men were making out or
something they would shoot potatoes over
near them oh no way pretty bad stuff i
mean they weren't trying to endanger
them or anything i think they just
didn't want to surprise them yeah i
think they just didn't want them doing a
lot of drugs and making out in the water
they didn't want anybody to drown
because some men had drowned okay so it
was almost like lifeguarding a little
bit but but that was like the most
extreme sport i ever saw was people with
these potato guns you know yeah um
i think anyway you rode a bike yeah i
rode a bike yeah but i never really
thought much of it we used to build the
ramp you know somebody always liked the
ramp like was a poorly built and this
part would come out and then somebody
the handlebar would turn and went into
some guy's body one time i remember yeah
but pretty [ __ ] we were pretty pretty
[ __ ] ex-gamers
oh well that's right but i think i could
probably get out there i would love to
get out there and try that would be sick
i could i could teach you like safely to
do it too yeah you say we could get you
flying yeah i think i'd be willing to we
had like a role a place called roller
kingdom bus where we'd have all our
birthday parties yeah and uh
dude this one kid this kid jeremy who we
were buddies with at the birthday
parties he would go and get all the gum
from like under the tables and make a
huge like and by the end of the birthday
party he would be chewing the biggest
gum dude he was twisted bro that's crazy
oh he was so twisted dude he did it
every [ __ ] time bro
he just had this ultimate thing of gum
dude
and his nobody would even his parents i
guess weren't paying attention to him
because
when they came to pick him they wouldn't
even ask him he couldn't even open his
mouth one time he had so much [ __ ]
coming he's just breathing through his
nose and his mom's like you're doing
great jeremy you know
so [ __ ] that's the next game right
now yeah that's pretty extreme yeah
that's the kind of extreme sports that
we had
nice
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one